i hit intros kakegurui season 2 episode
1.
we kick things off with a friendly
gamble between yumiko and midari who are
up against a new face in irimi mushibami
and the mediator for the match is inaho
yamato irimi had made a finger cutting
guillotine where the blade is held up by
a random string
contestants take turns cutting strings
one by one
until the blade falls and if you take
your finger out you lose
irimi had rigged the game so that their
fingers are actually protected but she
learns that while they were asked to
leave the room
yumiko may have had the mediator remove
the plating protecting their fingers
with this new knowledge she starts to
panic while typical yumiko
and midari are kinda getting off on the
whole situation jump on over to karari
who explains that the student council is
being dissolved to shake things up in
response to yumiko targeting them
she will also be giving up her
presidency in order to hold an election
to see if anybody can compete with her
we also get the introduction of members
of the momobami clan who have been
called in by kirari
we have toronto and yumi totobami sumika
walraka kubami
miyo ingbami miroslava hombami
nozomi kombami the brothers reign and
ibarra ombami
miri yobami irimi mushibami who was the
finger guillotine chick
and their servant giving the
introduction reibotsubami
episode 2 they are all distant relatives
and the leader of their clan is kirari
even though none of them really like her
or each other over the next 30 days the
election will be held with each student
getting one chip
representing a vote and whoever gets the
most of these chips at the end will
become president
the momobami clan are all interested in
winning so that they can take over
hiyako academy and force kirari to step
down as leader of the clan we also
learned that yumiko is apparently a
distant relative
in the momobami clan but no one seems to
know how they're related now we're gonna
go ahead and jump on back up to the
present to the finger guillotine bet
it comes down to the last two strings
and midari cuts
both strings at the same time in a panic
irimi withdraws her finger as it's
falling
luckily the plating protecting their
fingers was never removed in the first
place so yumiko amidara's fingers are
safe
also yumiko had a hunch about the play
and made it seem like the mediator had
removed it but really she didn't
in the end irimi loses for taking her
finger out midari is disqualified for
cutting two strings at once leaving
yumiko
as the winner yumiko is pretty pissed
off about this because she feels like
midari had robbed her of
the ecstasy of only having one string
left making her hate midari even more
episode three we get a quick scene of
yuriko as she collapses after losing a
bet against miri and mio
later on rey introduces the two of them
to yumiko because the three of them were
invited to some sort of election battle
the lolly runa makes her reappearance as
she is there to act as the impartial
moderator
suzue is feeling off about this match so
he decides that he's going to join in
at the last minute the game they're
going to be playing is decided by roona
and is called nim type
zero where there are 4 cards 0 through 3
and each player takes turns playing a
card and the player that brings the
total value of the cards on the table to
over 10
loses they are also allowed to bet with
chips that represent
24 hours worth of servitude toward the
student council
meanwhile mary is approached by rabrika
who offers
mary the opportunity to win a hundred
votes the drawback is that if she loses
she will be forced to join rurika's
campaign
but anyways back to the others where in
the first hand everyone bets their 30
chips and
mio ends up losing the first round we
then see that mary was being led to
believe that she was gambling against
the president but when she finds out
that it was her twin sister she refuses
to play
mary then gets a call from suzue who
says that there's something wrong
when mio initially met yumiko she went
on to poison her and now that the poison
is starting to kick in yumiko has
collapsed
after hearing this mary wins the hundred
bets and proceeds to sit in for yumiko
to play against miri and mio the
conditions of the bet are changed a
little bit because now they are also
playing for the antidote to the poison
that is afflicting yumiko
everybody comes to the agreement that
the antidote should be worth around 100
votes and after each
round the loser of that round will have
to prick their finger on a needle that
has the poison on it in the last couple
of scenes mary orders suzue to show
everyone at the table his cards
he agrees to this because shortly after
yumiko had been afflicted with the
poison
she told him to trust mary he places all
of his cards face up on the table and
after doing so
mary feels confident enough to win so
she bets all 100 of her votes
episode 4. during the second round of
the match we learned that miri and mio
have some sort of telepathic
communication that allows them to talk
without saying a ward
they use this to discuss their hands and
strategize on how to defeat mary
mary instructs suzue on which cards he
needs to play and she is able to guide
them to a victory in the second round
as well the other girls aren't out of it
just yet because they have multiple
antidotes each valuing at 100 votes so
they get to keep playing
even after winning the round they
technically get the antidotes but they
can't use it until the game is finished
on top of that miri is forced to prick
her finger on a poison since she lost
the last round
in the third round mary raises ten
thousand votes using 24 hour chips
ichiman bio
after everybody is done calling mary
reveals that runa was using the gill
breath shuffle which was making the
order of cards predictable
since miri and mio didn't pick up on
this they were a hundred percent going
to lose from the start miyo turns out to
be a bit of a heartless [ __ ] and
instructs miri to lose which would force
her into basically permanent servitude
towards the student council
before she can do this though she ends
up collapsing because of the poison that
she was afflicted with in the previous
round
this ultimately makes them forfeit and
mary and suzuey win
yumiko is rushed to the infirmary and
rey tells them how to administer the
antidote so that she survives
mary also tells the unconscious yumiko
that she is gunning for becoming
president also
not that it really matters because she's
[ __ ] unconscious now we jump on over
to kirari who is continuing to smash
nerds and collecting a good amount of
election chips
in the last scene we see that she has
some new challengers when members of the
momobami clan come looking for her
episode 5. the election has now been
going on for over a week at this point
and we get a rundown of the standings
kirror is killing pretty much everybody
in the standings comfortably sitting in
first place after her victory against
the momo bobby clan members from the
last episode yamiko is still technically
in the running but she is pretty far
behind
sitting in 10th place yumemi then makes
her reappearance in order to ask
yumiko to perform on stage with her
again and bet against
fans in order to pick up some easy chips
that was the original plan
until one of yumemi's idols a movie star
named natari kawaru shows up
her real name is actually sumika
warakubami and she is a part of the
momobami clan as well
she challenges both yumiko and yumemi to
a concert consisting of showing off
three performances
the first round is singing where yumiko
and yumemi perform a pop song that
people seem to respond really well to
that doesn't seem to last long though
and they get rolled by natari who sings
amazing grace and wins the vote 8 to 92.
this is a serious stomp especially
considering that yumemi had
bribed most of the audience to vote for
her instead
episode 6 the only logical conclusion
that yumemi could come up with as to why
she lost
is because natari must have found out
about the bribing and offered a higher
bribe to ensure that the contest was
judged fairly
in the next round they play a game
called grin and barrett death macaroon
where each contestant eats three
macaroons but one of them is extremely
spicy
they then have to guess which macaroon
that their opponent ate was the spicy
one based off of their reaction
testing their acting skills to make it
seem like she was intense
pain you mimi breaks her own fingers so
it would seem convincing
in the end she ends up just looking like
a [ __ ] idiot for breaking her own
finger because natari sees right through
the act and pinpoints the right macaroon
anyways
luckily yumiko comes in clutch with her
guests based off of nothing at all and
the round ends up being a tie
for the third round players place cards
face down declaring a value
and if the total of all the cards
exceeds 63 then the last person who
played a card loses
whoever wins this round will get double
points so the first two rounds were just
for show and mean nothing at all
at first yumiko is disgusted with how
overwhelmed yumemi is acting so she
refuses to work with her
towards the end of the round yummy goes
through a series of self reflections
gains a little bit of confidence and
asks yumiko to pass allowing her to pass
as well
when the total of the cards is revealed
it is over 63
and since yumiko and yumemi had passed
their turns nitari was the last one who
played a card making her
the loser episode 7 for the first time
yumiko initiates a challenge of her own
against toronto she has no interest in
taking up other people's votes so
toronto offers up her votes as a reward
to five players who all agree to compete
in the greater good game
the other contestants are itsuki
sumuragi miroslava hombami
yumiko jabami ibara obami and finally
kade manuta with rumia uru residing over
as the moderator
this is a game of deceit where players
go into a separate room and distribute
coins between a personal piggy bank for
themselves and a tax box that doubles
the value of the coins for the good of
all of the players
the coins from the tax box are
redistributed and they repeat the
process
and the player with the most coins after
five rounds wins
in the beginning yumiko suggests that
everybody places their coins into the
tax box
after the first round when the coins are
redistributed to the players there are
only 20 coins meaning that somebody
betrayed them
and put coins into their personal bank
if the group decides that they know who
the trader is then they have the power
to remove them from the game but at this
point they aren't
sure yumiko decides to take a different
approach suggesting that each player get
a piece of paper that will tell them how
many coins to put into the tax box
hopefully
exposing the trader this isn't working
out because now there are even fewer
coins meaning that there could be two
traders collaborating everyone is
throwing suss on everyone else until
kade who doesn't seem too invested
says that he actually thinks the traitor
is yumiko
episode 8 kade gives his reasoning for
the suspicions on yumiko and the
distrust amongst the players continues
to grow
things continue to go downhill because
in round three there are only
15 coins placed into the tax box kade
and yumiko both decide to shake things
up a bit by telling them that they are
no longer placing coins into the tax box
and they will all just go down together
this is enough convincing for everybody
to come together and put their coins
into the tax box for round four
after hearing that all of the coins were
placed in the tax box kade comes to the
conclusion that the traders are likely
miroslava
itsuki was leaving notes in the other
room for miroslava to find in order to
cooperate together for the win
this means that miroslava likely had the
most coins in the group and so everybody
decides to vote her out itsuki wins with
45 coins earning the top prize of a
hundred votes
itsuki wanted to bring kate out of his
slump after his loss to yumiko which is
why she drug him into the bet in the
first place
she had bet on him winning because she
believed in his skills and even if she
lost she would still be happy that he
was the winner so there was really no
downside because toronto had won the
third party bet itsuki ends up having to
pay her 150 votes basically negating all
of her winnings
itsuki then withdraws from the election
because she wasn't really interested in
winning she just wanted to help out kade
episode 9. roona again gives the
standings of the top 10 where kirari is
still ahead of everybody
else toronto has closed the gap after
her wager with itsuki putting her
in second place and yumiko is now in
sixth place
during their little meet up to discuss
the standings and have all the
contestants talk a bit yumiko ends up
challenged kirari out of nowhere
saiyaka igarashi is kirari's secretary
and has some sort of weird obsession
with her so she steps in to white knight
her challenging yumiko with their lives
on the line that's a little bit too
boring for yumiko so the stakes are
changed to sayaka will give up any
interaction with kirari
against yumiko will never gamble again
the game is tower of doors where kirari
also says that the losers should jump
from the top floor and kill themselves
basically negating everything we just
talked
about both contestants have to solve
problems that will open doors and trap
doors to get to the first floor
grab a flower and then return to the top
floor yumiko's first door is a dead end
so she can't go anywhere while sayaka
opens a trapdoor moving down one floor
on yumiko's next turn she takes a risk
by opening a door that leads to the
outside in the last scene
episode 10. we learn about roona's
running prediction that a lot of the
votes are actually being held as proxies
for the front runners which will likely
have a huge
unexpected impact in the voting at the
end but anyways back to the game even
though sayaka manages to get to the
first floor and retrieve her flower
yumiko is right on her heels showing up
one turn after
zayaka is still convinced that she can
beat her on the ascent back up to the
top of the tower but when she gets there
yumiko is already there
yumiko had come to the conclusion that
the outer part of the tower
rotates after having opened one of the
outer doors and noticed that she
couldn't see the moon
since only the outer part rotates she
knew that the wall
initially blocking the inner door
wouldn't be there so she uses the
central stairs to ascend and descend in
two turns winning the race
sayaka eats herself out of the outer
door as part of the bet and to her
horror kirari had jumped with her
they both survived thanks to the door
they jumped out of being the one that
leads to a padded landing preserving
their lives
we get some yuri vibes fired up which i
was a fan of until hirori licks blood
off of sayaka and the confusion just
killed my razzle even though she had
lost kirari asked her to be the
secretary again which i didn't think was
allowed but i don't care enough to argue
about it
episode 11. a number of students receive
an invitation to a hundred votes auction
including yumiko and satome yumiko suzui
maria rico midari and rorica are the
only ones who got invitations and
accepted ray will be the one
acting as the auctioneer and inaho is
the mediator in the first round mary
wins
earning herself 80 votes but with the
others who bid there is an
unknown beneficiary that collects 130
votes
the second round is won by nishitonin
for 80 votes
also in the third round mary has a
realization that there is another bidder
and she accuses rey which she admits to
and says that she will sit the fourth
round out
after that yumiko exposes that rey is
not only the auctioneer but she is also
the sponsor benefiting from the bids
in response to this realization yumiko
has 3 billion yen which is all of the
winnings she got from her match with
kate in season 1 put
on the line as a challenge to the real
ray this proxy raid to take on her true
form by removing the disguise she was
wearing
episode 12. we get some backstory on rey
while she was working as a servant to
the momobami clan
she was always treated poorly except for
one lady who was kind to her but the
momobommi clan destroyed that lady
through gambling
rey sets out on a quest for revenge
against the momobami clan for what they
had done to the lady
her plan is to win the election and if
she does that then she can take hirari's
position
as head of the momobami clan and exact
her vengeance on the members
she explains that she is using votes
collected from students betting on
whether she would win the election
everyone realizes that they're in too
deep now and have to continue even if it
means risking all of the votes that they
have accumulated and uriko wins the next
bid with 99 votes
yumiko devises a new strategy to bid 101
votes which intimidates the others from
bidding you are essentially spending
votes to get votes and since each bid is
worth 100 votes
then by bidding 101 you'll actually lose
one vote if you win
everyone involved starts to pick up on
her strategy and
only one bidder bids one vote each round
forcing
rey to lose all of her votes after rey
is out yumiko suggests one more bid
the three billion yen that rey is
allowed to gamble with
up against yumiko giving up the jabami
name decided by the flip of a coin
i'm not really too sure what she was
trying to accomplish with this i guess
she just wanted the opportunity to go
against rey one-on-one but she ends up
winning the coin flip at the end
in the last couple of scenes we get a
montage of all of the characters and we
see that yumiko had actually lost
a lot of the winnings that she had got
from the auction from random gambles
around the campus
i'm gonna be doing the next season and
you can find that on the left side or
you can check out all of the kakegurui
videos in the playlist on the right side
you can also find the links in the
description below and the only thing i
hate more than intros is outros